hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast integrating the digital
universe of data with consumer driven
mobile apps and large-scale pandemics
data to better understand treat and
prevent disease I am seen we have lab
roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event today so educational web
seminar is presented by lab roots the
leading scientific social networking
site and provider of virtual events and
webinars advancing scientific
collaborations and learning before we
start there a few instructions we want
to hear from you during this interactive
broadcast so please ask questions or
leave as a comment answers are welcome
to you can do this by hitting the green
Q&A button at the lower left of the
presentation window and typing in your
question in commons we'll try to answer
as many questions as you can and we'll
follow up today with you if you don't
have time do you want a better look you
can enlarge a slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
can't hear this presentation properly
let us know by clicking on their support
button at the top right or use a Q&A
button will make sure to resolve any
issues this is an educational web
seminar and this provides free
continuing education credits after the
webinar is over please click on the CD
button located at the bottom left hand
corner of your web page and follow the
process of obtaining your credits now
let's get to today's speaker we're proud
to present dr. Eric chef Eric shack is
PhD and director of icon Institute for
genomics and multiscale biology chair of
the department of genetics and genomics
sciences and the gene c and james w
crystal professor of genomics at the
Icahn School of Medicine at Mount Sinai
dr. Shetty is an expert in the
generation and integration of very large
scale sequence variation molecular
profiling and clinical data and disease
populations for constructing molecular
networks that define disease dates and
Link molecular biology to physiology he
is known for calling a shift in
molecular biology toward a network
oriented view of living systems to
complement the reductionist single scene
approaches that currently dominate
biology in order to accurately model the
complexity of biological systems he has
published more than 200 peer-reviewed
papers in leading scientific journals
and contributed to a number of
discoveries leading to the genetic basis
of common diseases such as diabetes
obesity and Alzheimer's disease I will
now turn it over to dr. Chad for his
presentation if word for joining so I'm
going to you know talk today about you
know some of the work I'm doing at Mount
Sinai on how do we you know leverage
sort of this consumer health revolution
and all the large-scale pandemic data to
better understand disease and one of the
things that I had um you know noted
early on and coming to a big medical
system like Mount Sinai was how so
finely tuned the system was you know to
this old model of you know really
wanting people to come in to the
hospital sick if they can pay and and if
you're able to pay the system just runs
you know a bunch a bunch of tests on you
and that's how they generate their
revenue and you know stay in business
and kind of overnight when I join
cyanide the Affordable Care Act was
taking place and it was just you know
put into law and and really created this
completely new model overnight for how
medicine needed to be practiced so away
from this fee-for-service sick care
delivery to now more of this health
maintenance you know how do we prevent
you from ever coming into the hospital
and one of the things that's problematic
about those sorts of transformations as
you know almost revolution is especially
in a big medical system like a Mount
Sinai or our orthodoxies so you know
orthodoxies or these long-held core
beliefs that are that are no longer true
or applicable in the current landscape
but they get adhered to
in any case just you know from from
historical sort of inertia perspective
and the these orthodoxies can you know
stifle creativity and innovation so as
you're thinking about how to transform a
big medical system you know to meet you
know this fundamental you know flip from
PP for service to care delivery to help
maintenance you're going to you're going
to run into these orthodoxies and of
course it's not specific either to you
know big medical systems like Mount
Sinai on you have one of my favorites
you know throughout human history is mr.
Warner in 1927 talking about you know
who's ever going to want to hear
somebody talk during a movie so that's
that's kind of the mindset that experts
get into very narrow mindset where
they're no longer thinking outside of
the box no longer being as creative so
we need to be able to disrupt that you
know that that's sort of mindset and one
way that gets disrupted and we've
certainly seen this in medicine and in
biological research in general is
through technology obviously we've been
you know in the midst of a really an
amazing revolution on the on the
technology side from you know the
Internet of Things to next-generation
sequencing to big data analytics to
cloud-based computing and you know
management of your life and so on these
sorts of technologies coming into play
to transform how we can acquire data how
how we can assess somebody's individual
wellness and a few of my favorites are
this particular product you know sort of
this handheld spectrometer where your if
you want to understand what you're
eating you no longer having to keep the
diary you can point the handheld
spectrometer at what you're eating and
get the chemical decomposition you know
which which i think is a very cool and
you know we have companies like like
theranos so you know the ability now you
know moving towards this ability to
enable individuals to walk into you know
their neighborhood pharmacy and get any
number of tasks that normally would have
been you know restricted or constrained
to getting within the hospital system
and so we know that theranos and others
are having some regulatory hurdles to
get over
you know to make this also but this sort
of day coming where we're again it's no
longer care needing to be given within
the medical system it can happen outside
closer to your home we have companies
like sanguine bio again this is one of
my favorites or when you think about the
uber ization of medicine you know
sanguine is out there uh you know
delivering care services directly into
the home so you're no longer having to
go into your medical system to
participate say in a clinical trial so
clinical trials are sort of their bread
and butter today they'll bring the
clinical trials into your home so from
the standpoint of you know getting
better patient engagement better
retention you know broader breadth of
patients I can be tested you know this
is sort of a cool again transformation
that we're seeing occurring in real time
and then you know one of my favorites is
this company transcript 'ok run by a
young guy out of stanford robotics guy
where the aim is to you know basically
automate all of these sophisticated
biological workflows that you know if
you want to enable somebody to be
sitting on the beach in hawaii thinking
of an experiment they need to do you can
literally go to the web page select what
kind of protocol you want to run select
what samples what kind of samples you
want to have run like whether it's a
targeted sequencing essay or some series
of cell-based assays where you want to
assess phenotypes you can actually do
this you know now over the web through
their web page that experiment gets
executed on their series of robotic
robots in their big warehouse you know
very cool just to when you start
thinking about how do we standardize
science how do we standardize these
workflows and monitor them at a much
more granular level than we do today
this is a you know company that's going
to you know how take us there so all of
this kind of technology coming to play
in impacting the ability for us to
understand ourselves and to understand
biology and disease better it really
creates these three interwoven elements
that I think define digital health or
sort of this mobile health element where
it's all about the analytics to leverage
day
from mobile or network devices there's
the sort of the quantified self idea
where you can leverage all these
technologies again to score lots of high
dimensional data on yourself and again
do that longitudinally and then of
course all important health IT which is
how do we manage all of that information
between consumers and providers and
governments and pay and payers to you
know basically have the biggest impact
we can so in my opinion you know the
future role of a hospital like a Mount
Sinai is how do we push that care you
know out out out of the hospital in
closer to the home right so again we
we're moving into this health
maintenance you know only getting
reimbursed when you have a benefit sort
of you know that you know type of
medicine in so we want people to stay
well right we don't want them coming in
sick and so I sort of view this you know
some of the analogs on on what I see the
future of medical systems would be you
know think about the largest car company
in the world today so that would be uber
and they own no cars right the largest
hotel chain in the world today air B&B
and they own no hotels so in my view the
the medical system the largest medical
systems in the future are going to own
no hospitals right there going to be
managing patient care assessing a
patient's condition or a well
individuals condition through again
leveraging the technologies that data
that's acquired on you is going to be
crunched on big super computers using
advanced analytics and instead of the
doctors you know start instead of going
into the doctor's office to figure out
what's going on with you and he's
holding the stethoscope on you it's
going to be you know a NASA style
command and control center that's
basically helping assess your conditions
in real-time and preventing you from
sliding into catastrophic disease states
so intervening before you're you know
having to show up in the emergency room
from some catastrophic event and so the
types of apps we've been developing
towards this end or you know geared
towards you know how can we you know
basically improve patient wellness
better manage conditions that are
obviously happening outside the Medical
Center in
and potentially intervene you know
before a patient slides into such a
catastrophic state that they require you
know hospitalization so while there you
know literally tens of thousands of apps
out available on the web today that
relate to health you know so why are we
why are we thinking we can can't do any
different or better than all the myriad
of apps be made available and it's
really the focus on leveraging
technology and having a more clinically
oriented validated context in which you
know to use these apps so our studies
are all centered around when we're
designing these apps like are we are we
reducing disease related to distress and
the individuals who use the app are we
on decreasing hospital um you know
health care utilization so right they
stay more well they're not having to go
into the hospital as often do we get
better symptom control better medication
compliance and so on so all of these
different variables we actually are
carrying out clinical tests or you know
in a sense clinical trials to help
assess the utility of the kind of apps
we develop you know so that's one key
for differentiating from the big myriad
of apps that are out there the other is
you know we want to again use these apps
to acquire lots of data around
individuals and to manage that
information compute on it you know do
the appropriate analytics that we can
then feed back to the patients or to the
whole system regarding their wellness so
we you know investing in the type of web
scalable infrastructure you need to you
know to play that game is something
we've gone a great at great lengths to
do and you know so bringing on board
guys like a jackhammer Bakr who you know
as a founding chief data scientist a
Facebook and then founded Cloudera which
is how do we bring Hadoop out competing
to the masses but now here at Sinai
helping us you know play that web
scalable architecture game here uh and
then of course we needed the right kind
of partners and you know developing the
kinds of apps we were interested in to
help you know better manage patient
chronic disease conditions and better
manage individuals wellness and as we
know as scientists were just were not
you know maybe so
tuned with you know what's the best way
to engage consumer and the use of you
know the this type of digital media so
we partnered with groups like Apple we
were among the first institutions to
build applications on top of health kit
and research kit and then leveraging
digital agencies like life map solutions
who's our key partner in developing
these mobile health apps and in y media
labs again just experts at you know user
interface user experience product design
and so on so one of the first apps we
made was for managing chronic disease
conditions around asthma and copd so in
this app again the the hope here is that
we can better engage a patient in their
conditions aggregate more information
around them better understand their
condition and that that's ultimately
going to you know benefit the individual
through better you know they'll be more
well have less severe disease better
control of their disease and so on so
what do we get with the asthma health
app what do we solve that we thought was
pretty um you know useful from the
standpoint of doing research in this way
so first of all we were able to solve
with apple electronic consenting so the
app allows individuals to electronically
consent into IRB approved research to
share their data that's aggregated
around them to consent to having data
collected on them and so on and all of
that's done electronically and why that
matters is we want to be able to UM
scale this to really big numbers right
we don't want to do the traditional
research study where we have four or
five hundred patients collected over a
couple of years we want it we want to
get to the millions of individuals so
with the asthma health app you know we
had that app online for a couple of
weeks roughly 50,000 people downloaded
that app from the App Store and of those
50,000 on the order of 9,000 made it
through the consenting process to enroll
in an IRB approved study for asthma and
that happened in a couple of weeks so in
a couple of weeks time for the cost of
developing the app we you know growth
hacked up one of the largest asthma
cohorts in the US and
and what are the what are we doing
without you so we're not only
aggregating lots of information on those
individuals but we're feeding that
information back to them so this is just
one of the infographics that we have
just to show you the sheer scale of data
we're collecting on this and let me see
if I can use some of my little tools
here to point some things out so so
first of all you see here this wheel is
we got individuals enrolled in that app
from all 50 states so again think of
traditional PR you're outta academic
Medical Center some research institution
you're wanting to do one of these
studies you have to hire a clinical
coordinator you're only getting patients
that are within your geographic locale
whereas with with these apps we're able
to cast a net over the entire US and we
just announced yesterday with Apple that
we now have this app running in the UK
and Ireland and soon we'll be in China
so we we can cast a much broader net we
get a handle on all the different types
of medications that are being used by
these individuals both both the
maintenance medication as well as acute
treatment medication we get all of the
types of exacerbations you know the
frequency of exacerbations the asthma
attacks the cause of those asthma
attacks and so on so it's just a
tremendous amount of information that
way better assesses the individuals
condition longitudinally then then you
would get from a 10 minute visit 10
minute visit in a doctor's office so
again we think very transformational and
again you're able to provide this
information back to the user right
you're giving the user of the app all of
this feedback around their condition how
active are they being how many times
have they popped on their inhaler how
many exacerbations have they had on what
are the causes of those exacerbations
and do they correlate with increased
pollen counts in you know pollution
levels and temperature and so on in fact
when we one of the first trends we noted
in this app was the wildfires in
Washington State Becca in last summer
and seeing a correlation between the
increased pollution levels resulting
from those wildfires and increase
reporting of asthma attacks in
Washington State as a result so so very
cool on sort of real-time monitoring of
an environmental impact on
disease conditions so so again we want
to so we want to collect all this
information on individuals to better
understand their condition on the app's
we have coming as a phase two will
collect in addition to all of the app
related data will be able to consent you
to pull down your medical EMR data will
be able to collect DNA and run assays on
the on the DNA and so on today we have a
biobank at Mount Sinai where we've done
this in thirty-five thousand individuals
and again once you start getting this
kind of density of information on
individuals there's a lot you can do so
what are the kinds of things we've done
in you know sort of growth hacking up
large patient populations where we have
very deep phenotyping and molecular
information generated on them here's one
of the papers Joel Dudley's group and my
Institute had out in Science
Translational Medicine where they
leverage that 35,000 person biobank
looked at hundreds of features from that
bio bank that related to type 2 diabetes
then they clustered the type 2 diabetes
population using a topological data
analysis algorithm from my oz D so this
plot here is from the I oz D software
you know very cool if you've not seen
that before it's a good data mining tool
I you so you can see the group's um
broke out in three different subtypes
again so this is clustering the type two
diabetics and that population across
hundreds of features and the interesting
thing about these different subgroups
where they were enriched for very
different comorbidities of the disease
so for example if you're in the subtype
one group you're much more likely to
suffer from blindness or vision defects
versus if you're subtype to you're more
likely to suffer from a sort of an
immune deficient phenotype greater risk
of infections and cancer and then
subtype 3 is more of a common run of the
mill metabolic syndrome phenotype so
pretty cool like that's of interest
right to payers to population health
managers your ability to risk stratify
into different groups and assign
different types of resources to those
groups to prevent
morbidities again one of the great
potentials I think in the future another
another example is you know so remember
we're collecting DNA on these
individuals we're seeking the sequencing
those at high impact genes so now we can
think about doing special kinds of
searches not not just in the sense of
this disease but in sense of how can we
identify individuals who continuous into
therapeutics that can treat whole
disease groups so we have this idea of
the resilience project a published on
this in science last year with a Steven
friend at Sage bio networks where the
idea is can we identify individuals who
harbor highly penetrant dilla terious
mutations that should have caused
catastrophic illness and childhood but
they're in their 40s and 50s and have
never manifested those diseases right so
that those are pretty special
individuals that however they're
buffering the disease you know as a
therapeutic so think of you know
examples like pcsk9 for heart disease or
ccr5 for HIV infection but this is a
more systematic search over a broader
set of diseases and if we can identify
these resilient individuals they again
they're sort of a pharmacologic proof of
concept that nature's provided us to
figure out how to better treat disease
so we have a paper and press should be
out any day now where we did this kind
of search retrospectively on six hundred
thousand genomes so again the search was
medical textbooks as if you have this
mutation you have this disease so one
hundred percent penetrant deleterious
mutation so think of things like cystic
fibrosis and tay sachs and so medical
textbook says you should have had this
bad disease in your childhood but you're
in your 40s and 50s and we found you and
you don't have that so we searched six
hundred thousand genomes in that way and
identify 13 individuals spanning eight
different diseases who are resilient to
this catastrophic illnesses and that
those included a couple of like cystic
fibrosis cases so again once we have
those individuals now we can think about
decoding them understanding how they
buffered the disease so the so so now we
want to you know you know even go
further beyond the genetics in just the
classification and go into how can we
mechanistically understand what's going
on with disease and
come up with better ways of both
understanding for diagnosis and
treatment but the way we engage this
information has a big impact on how we
um you know how we might solve a problem
and one of the study's I saw that was
very influential to me and showing how
were prevented with him presented with
information you know matters from the
standpoint of solving problems two
groups right were given a problem to
solve it was a fix the candle to the
wall light the candle without wax
dripping on the wall or the table the
two groups were given the exact same
instructions and presented with the data
in exactly the same way with the
exception of group two they were given
the tax outside of the box versus group
one whoops was given the tax inside of
the box so that was the only difference
and on average group to solve the
problem twice as fast is group one so
really subtle difference in how
information is presented can lead to
very big differences and how you solve a
problem or how efficiently you solve the
problem so again it comes down to right
the more expert we are it's almost like
the deeper the grooves are in our brain
it's the more narrow narrowly we think
the less creative less innovative we can
be so it's very paradoxical and of
course we see this throughout many
industries not just biological research
in medicine and one of my favorites has
always been the IBM or IBM BMW and kind
of a speed freak and you know driving
s1000rr Superbike from BMW m5 and BMW
wanted to set engineers with their
customers to figure out how they could
make their products better and so they
you know did does a customer want better
acceleration or cornering or breaking so
the engineer SAT with you know the
customers and drove around and they were
shocked to learn that nearly universally
the the feedback was that you know what
the customer wanted nothing to do with
performance it had to do with not
causing damage to car pulling into and
out of a parking space like pretty
pretty unexpected the engineer certainly
didn't expect a non-performance feature
to be the number one feature the
customer wanted but that's how they
innovated the park assist features so
BMW was the first to do that and again
they did it through this objective
acquisition of data on the on the
biological side in in particular in the
field I'm in in genomics and genetics um
the problem is we focus on one single
dimension and try to drive lots of
meaning from that in this case genetics
the problem is genetics is necessary but
not sufficient so we of course know it's
necessary right genetics ultimately you
know fundamentally decides whether
you're you know going to be a frog or a
human more subtle variation speaks to
your risk of different types of diseases
or you know more subtle phenotypic
variation in a population but we know
that's not sufficient because you know
simply understanding what a
disease-causing gene is doesn't
necessarily lead to an understanding of
that disease so we you know one of the
easy examples of Huntington's disease
we've known that disease gene for 30
years a Mendelian disorder yep 30 years
later after discovering that gene and
lots of research we still don't know how
that gene causes Huntington's how that
disease progresses how do we prevent it
how do we treat it how do we cure it so
right we got knowledge from that but not
understanding and I'd like to think of
it in terms of you know genetics looking
at averages and populations and how
individuals respond to a given allele or
a mutation and I'd like to equate that
to you know can you understand a human
biology the disease biology by looking
at averages and I'll equate it to your
ability to look at this video clip
that's playing so a Nike commercial and
what you see in the commercial are lots
of activities happening lots of objects
all occurring in synchrony and you know
flowing together and your minds doing an
amazing job of figuring of looking at
all of that information and assessing
what's going on and then making a
determination about the intent well you
can know better understand the
complexity of that clip or I'm sorry you
can know better understand the
complexity of biology by looking at
averages and the genetics and you can
understanding this clip by looking at
the average of all the frames in that
clip averaging all of the pixels that
occur through each frame in the clip and
looking at the average that that's
what's depicted here so what's depicted
here is the average
all the frames that it just showed you
in that video clip and of course you
can't gain any understanding of that um
clip from from the average of course
biologists are very clever and they
don't stick to just looking at the
genetics of the averages they can do
specific interventions specific
perturbations and so we see this here
with the looking at for example you know
how does Rosie glitter zone increase
insulin secretion from islets and so
what the biologists did was say okay
well ppargamma is the target of
rosiglitazone and through
experimentation when we disturb
ppargamma disrupts abca1 which disrupts
cholesterol regulation which goes on to
insulin secretion so through that sort
of linear reductionist reasoning you can
get some understanding that's useful but
just back to the video clip analogy it
doesn't give you complete understanding
it gives you just a slice and so what
you're looking at in this plot here is a
single one-dimensional line through the
through the video frames and I'm just
plotting the pixel intensities for that
one dimension of pixels that one line of
pixels and again it gives you a lot more
information than the average but you
still can't understand that video clip
by you know doing that so what we've
been advocating for you know now for you
know maybe 15 years is a you know
integrating data more holistically to
build these predictive models that can
guide us and how we think about disease
so here you're seeing lots of different
types of data whether its molecular or
clinical or consumer acquired data being
brought together and highly nonlinear
ways to form these networks and of
course the network's don't act in
isolation they act in concert and a
network of networks and so understanding
how his systems put together in this way
is what's going to help us achieve
understanding so we can start looking at
things not a single gene at a time but a
network of interaction of variables at a
time and so we can be in a single cell
or tissue type where we see you know
changes in one part of the system how
they propagate through to another part
of the system so say this is again in a
single cell or tissue type but we know
we're more complicated than the single
cell or tissue type so we want to model
things
at a more holistic level so we're
looking actually at you know all the
different organ systems and
understanding the information flow
throughout so once we're able to do this
we can place things oops sorry uh we can
place things in the context a more
holistic context so we can build these
network models depicted here and
understand the action of a given gene
and in this richer context so we're no
longer looking at a simple linearly
ordered pathway we're looking at the
fuller context in which that gene
operates and just to give you an example
of back to the video analogy is here it
it gives you not a perfect
representation of what's happening in
the in the video but it gives you more
information you can start recognizing
patterns and you know would claim that's
more useful and so again we you know use
these types of network modeling to
uncover you know brand new biology about
disease but again in a more holistic way
so here's a gene p p.m. 1l that we had
published on a few years ago that sits
next to ppargamma it's in the same you
know it gets affected by ppargamma and
changes in it affect people are gamma
and our model predicted that if you're
down so red is down green is up in this
particular slide if you knock down p
p.m. 1l it's going to increase insulin
levels it's going to decrease glucose
levels but it's also going to increase
fat mass levels and it's also going to
affect genes that are involved in
hypertension or cardiovascular disease
so it may increase your cardiovascular
risk we of course went on and
prospectively validated those
predictions and all the predictions we
made based on that model we're true so
higher glucose levels are not I'm sorry
so knocking the gene down decrease
glucose levels but also increase fat
mass and also increased blood pressure
so increased cardiovascular risks so
published that in nature and just
showing you that you know these models
can be very predictive and in fact what
I like most about this story was the PPM
one else is next to ppargamma again
they're in the same a signaling pathway
or network and but two years we
published a paper in Nature two years
before
avandia the clinical reports came out in
publication that avandia increases your
cardiovascular risk so again this is
just something that you know we were
able to show in silico that this sort of
problem would exist we didn't have to
wait to see it in a big you know
market-based trial where people you know
we're coming in with cara mia heart
attacks from taking the drug so again we
think this systems based approaches is
really the way to go to build these more
holistic models of disease and how best
to diagnose and treat disease for those
of you think this is a bit pinus guys
that you know biology isn't ready for
this I'll just point you to a paper
Jonathan Carr my group published and
sell a couple of years ago where he
provided one of the first ever fully
computational models of a living system
where he modeled in silico every aspect
of the system so it was it was a
primitive bacteria so only had like six
hundred genes so it wasn't a human cell
but it shows that we're going along the
way of being able to model every aspect
of what's going on in a cell from the
arm you know replication of the DNA to
the transcription to the metabolic flux
going through the system to the
translation like all of these processes
can now be modeled in what Jonathan
showed in his paper and this is the only
animation that's not going to play but
we don't really need it he showed just
showing in this graph oops what each one
of these lines indicates a different
cell being simulated in the computer and
the x axis is time and the y axis is
growth and ultimately division of the
cell so if the animation was playing you
should see this cell growing and
ultimately dividing bodhi did has had
all the different sets of pathways and
networks at play from the metabolics to
the replication to the translation all
being modeled simultaneously and driving
the phenotypes you should be seeing in
the animation and from that they were
able to simulate different perturbations
to the genes and came up with completely
novel insights on cell division and
growth that they then went on to
experimentally validate but that's the
sort of thing that you know is coming
for for biology and understanding of
systems and disease
we'll be this level of almost an
engineering type approach to to
understanding these systems since i'm
running a low short on time i'll say you
know we have done this at broader scale
now to understand human diseases one of
one of our innovations was on leveraging
DNA variation as a systematic
perturbation source to and for causal
relationships to build those kind of
models was highly predictive models for
disease so again just you know the idea
of Mendelian randomization done on a
systematic scale came out of this paper
we had in 2003-2004 where we
demonstrated you could leverage DNA
variation just like you could in a
clinical trial the randomization of an
individual to a placebo arm or a
treatment arm in a clinical trial you
know biology plays the same kind of game
in the mitotic divisions a random
assortment of chromosomes though so what
you inherit from your mom and dad are
you know sort of randomly chosen from
the random assortment of the chromosomes
so it's a it's a randomization mechanism
that allows us to do the causal
inference and from that we can play that
very systematically over the space of
all variables you know where we look for
the genetics that's affecting those
variables we apply some mathematics and
then we can infer causal relationships
among the whole space of variables and
that ultimately gets us to these network
models and just to close in the next few
minutes we have applied this to a great
number of diseases you know actually the
host indicated 200 papers I think I'm up
to around three hundred papers published
now we're again many you know
Alzheimer's obesity diabetes COPD asthma
IBD all of these involving you know
models like i just showed to help
understand disease and i'll just end
with this example of IBD where we took
all the genetic information that was
known at the time 163 genetic lo sai to
try to understand how those 163 those i
were causing a disease like inflammatory
bowel disease on so what we do is we
project that that data onto a bunch of
different network models and we search
for network models that inform that are
coherent with respect to the genes that
we're interested in so in this network
we found that this particular sub
network was very enriched fivefold
enrich for genes that Harbor variation
that cause IBD in the population so
those 163 IBD Lewis I were very enriched
in this part of the network so what this
network represents the pink in the
yellow nodes or so think of them as gene
expression trades DNA low sigh that
effect on those gene expression traits
are clinical variables or they could be
clinical variables and then the blue and
the pink or red edges or the causal
links that we infer from the data right
so so then once we have this sub network
identified that helps explain all of
those jeans that are causal for IBD we
can start you know drilling in and
looking at how those jeans are stuck
together and what are the genes that
actually modulate the state of this
disease causing network so again just as
Jonathan carded and silicon you're
modeling the bacteria in silico we can
do the same thing here and we can put
herb each gene in that IBD focus network
and then predict how does the network
respond to that perturbation and every
now and then we're going to encounter a
gene such as this one that lights up the
entire network right it alters the
entire state of the network we call that
a master regulator or key driver gene
and those are particularly important
because they play a more important role
in disease so from a therapeutic
intervention standpoint those are things
we want to be focused on and so here's
the IBD network that I was just showing
but now I broken it out by um structure
and so the bigger nodes here these are
the key driver genes that I was talking
about that are more central to the
modulation of the network these genes
are more proximal to the key driver
genes and these guys are more downstream
your purple edge if you're the key
regulator is up-regulating you your
green if it's down regulating you and
the importance of this structure is that
these key driver genes are 20 times more
likely to harbor variants that cause IBD
in the human population so they play a
much more critical role in the disease
then um you know just a random
geez chosen from that network so so we
focus a lot on those and what does that
do for us that gives us the ability to
make these maps to try to figure out how
can we better treat such diseases so now
what you're looking at here is a map of
the network that I was just showing you
for IBD the blue nodes but now we've
hooked it up to all marketed druggin and
natural products that's what the green
nodes are the green nodes are connected
the blue nodes if they're known or
predicted to interact with the coding
products of those nodes the purple pink
nodes are diseased traits so
disease-associated traits that are known
or predicted to respond to changes in in
these nodes or network state so you can
see that this is a much more complicated
dynamic going on it's not going to be a
single gene or a single drug that alters
that network in the right way that has
systemic benefit to all the different um
you know disease traits that are
associated with that network that is
going to have to be a combination of
things hitting that network in order to
have that kind of a role and so we do
this kind of systematic screening I
don't have the IBD one here this is for
psychiatric disorders what we're doing
but the idea is the same is that we can
now screen um you know cell systems
organoid systems and a in a you know
high-throughput screening context where
we're giving different types of drugs or
combinations of drugs to each of the
wells and we're looking at transcription
is a readout in mapping that
transcriptional read out to the
network's I just show to empirically
identify you know what are the
combinations of drugs that impact the
networks and the right way to have
benefit on on on the disease so that
sort of empirical phenotype phenotypic
based screening for the drug discovery
is what we on employ today and then I'll
just end with you know the future we
envision for all of this again are these
these networks informing individual
patients right so here you're seeing the
patients buzzing around and based on
their genetic information or
environmental information we're
interpreting them in the context of
these networks and identifying which
subsystems are disrupted in them or well
maintained to either predisposed to
disease
protect them from disease and once we
have these subsystems identified using
the mapping strategy I just talked about
we can match those patients to the right
type of intervention so whether it's a
small molecule or a change in your
behavior diet or exercise you know what
is it that can help you know keep you on
the trajectory you're on if it's a well
trajectory or bounce you off that
trajectory if it's a disease
predisposing or you're in a disease date
how'd it get you out of that disease
state so this is the type of guidance
that we see coming maybe in a five to
ten year time frame before we start
seeing that in play in some disease
areas but that's the goal we're shooting
for so with that I'll thank you for your
attention on this talk and just
recognize several of the groups at Mount
Sinai who are involved with this work
it's becoming a big group and then of
course we have a variety of academic
collaborators and Industry collaborators
that help of course with all the the
work we're doing so I guess I'll stop
there and hopefully there's some
questions thank you I was an excellent
presentation er thank you for bringing
that information to us before we get
started on the question any answer
separate session here's a quick reminder
about how to reach us today questions
can be sent via the green Q&A button at
the lower left of your presentation
window we'll get to as many questions as
we can our first question comes from
Beth at UCSF FF how does this idea of
moving health monitoring and so forth
closer to home translate to improving
care for under underserved populations
and countries under search sorry yeah I
got the question that's an excellent
question and I think you know we said in
Mount Sinai where you know we sit at the
border of the Upper East Side and harlem
so we're right adjacent to both the
richest one of the riches it goes in the
US as well as one of the poorest ZIP
codes in the US and of course we're a
community-based hospital system we serve
one of the most underserved populations
in the US and so out you know reaching
to them getting
those individuals is a top priority so
while we initially you know had our app
on the iPhone you know the iphone it's
it's more expensive so it's a little
more exclusive so they're not as
prevalent in underserved populations
supporting all of that over to the
Android systems is a big goal right
we're working with different groups on
porting research kit and right Apple
amazingly made that open source so
that's being ported to android our apps
are being ported to android and will
engage the underserved populations and
that way and we think this will be a big
benefit to them because it will again
enable them to have access to maybe
higher end you know abilities to
aggregate information and interpret it
then they might be able to get because
they're either underinsured or they
don't have access to the medical system
but we can potentially provide better
assessments on what's happening with
them outside of that system and one of
the examples I'll give where that's
already played out is in some of the
outreach around asthma turned out that
individuals coming into the ER because
of exacerbation for asthma a lot of them
in the underserved communities were
actually coming in not because they were
having an exacerbation but because they
ran out of their maintenance inhaler
jewson didn't simply didn't have the
money to get a repair replacement
inhaler so they come into the ER and get
one for free so now if we can better
monitor those individuals through the
apps on their android phone in assess
when they're out of inhaler fire a
prescription to the local CVS where they
can pick that up for free you know that
both helps them more convenient to get
their medication and it saves the health
system a $1,500 you know ER visit so
those are the kinds of impacts we hope
to have in the future great our next
question comes from bill at the southern
genomics Research Center who asks what
will be the future impact for the AI
integration into the Medical Society
just watching the dynamics from the
Boston Scientific or the dynamics the
one that google bought with the robots
and seeing all the robots are going to
take over and maybe I'll be treating us
as well I think though AI is going to
play a really fundamental role in you
know the kind of decision support
systems that can be manifested through
the apps to give better guidance to the
patients so today a lot of what we're
doing sort of needs to have of either a
physician intermediary or like a genetic
counselor for the testing they have to
be involved and you know the use of some
parts of the apps for conveying you know
medical information or information
around you and what we ultimately want
to gravitate towards for example is a
patient consumer-facing decision support
system that can take all of the data
that's being aggregated the models that
are being run and provide a meaningful
guidance back to the patient given
whatever their condition is so we
definitely see you know AI making its
way into apps and that kind of way and
we'll really be central to increasing
the utility of those apps from the
standpoint of making you know more
meaningful clinical interpretations of
the data and giving guidance to the
patient like that's going to be very
difficult to do without having a strong
AI platform in the mix that's very
interesting so are we have another
question from Jeanette at Indiana
University who asks how do you move from
managing chronic disease to preventing
chronic disease especially a chronic
disease with large environmental
behavior components like overeating not
enough exercise for smoking etc yeah
well i love it and i think i think the
you know what we all really want to be
focused on again is wellness like how do
we so we want to help the chronic you
know those with chronic diseases they
need help but what we really want to do
is get to people earlier before they
slide into those chronic disease
conditions and help prevent those and I
think there's a couple of ways we see
that happening first of all I think the
apps as the as
sensors around us that we can have on
our person become more integrated with
like our clothing so you no longer have
to conscientiously like bio jawbone up
monitoring device for your wrist it's
just worked into your clothing the
environmental sensors like as a you know
those things around a more as well curve
there they're going from recreation
grade research grade a clinical rate
grade at a really rapid pace so that
more passive monitoring of what's
happening where the user doesn't have to
be actively engaged you can better
assess what's going on in their
environment and on them or within them
so super key so we think the the passive
collection of data better sensors more
research clinical grade are going to
better enhance our ability to monitor
what's happening and in an individual
and then again the ability why I think
we need the next Steve Jobs you know
health is what are the right interfaces
to engage individuals in the use of that
information ways to incentive to pay
attention to you know modify their
behaviors like I view that as one of the
Holy Grails of you know of this kind of
game so I think we need to you know be
including those guys from Silicon Valley
that know how to growth hack up into the
hundreds of millions of users know how
to get people on he's consistently
coming back and paying attention to
whatever their product is like that's
the kind of thinking we need in these
mobile health apps to you know to really
make a difference and and I think the
algorithms and the guidance have to be
good enough you know to where those
using the apps perceive a benefit right
if they perceive a benefit they see
their life getting better they feel more
well or whatever the cases and they're
going to be more likely to um you know
keep coming back you know to whatever
the app is now those are great points
you have another question from Thomas at
planet connect who asks how does the ivd
work relate to the GI microbiome have
host microbe host microbe genomes been
associated I thought I
it brought up in my little network on
IBD because the network I highlighted
for you I didn't go into much depth on
the biology but it's all centered around
inflammation immune response sort of
characteristics so involving things like
macrophage cells and defense response
host defense response and so on and so
it's squarely in the host microbiome
interface so also all that whole network
is really defining the response of the
host network in the intestine to the
microbiome in shifts in the microbiome
that you know could cause catastrophic
problems with respect to inflammation in
the gut so it's you know front and
center in fact the study I have going
with yachts and pharmaceuticals from J&J
where we're looking at thousands of
individuals we biopsied their intestine
where RNA sequencing different biopsy
from IBD patients and controls and we're
also looking at their microbiome the gut
microbiome and attempting to more
directly link the function what's
functionally going on in the microbiome
with what's functionally going on in the
intestine but it's a you know really one
of the most central elements I think to
our understanding of IBD in the
microbiome this is front and center
ok we have a clarification from Thomas
who says thank you he meant from the
population shared data point of view and
he clarifies that will he ask will
mobile devices lead to social media
connections yeah maybe might have to
handle that one in an email I don't know
that I still fully get what you might be
asking but the certainly from the arm
like seeing companies like um I'm
totally blanking is I'm thinking a whole
biome which most of you may not have
heard of yet but you know these
companies that are doing more direct
consumer type testing of microbiome and
the type of role so think of the app
thats collecting lots of information on
you the sensors around you and so on you
know be awesome if one day one of those
sensors is you know looking at
monitoring what's what's coming out of
the sewage line of your house so all the
microbiome elements that are either
going through the toilet or down your
shower drain you know but there are
direct consumer you know things you can
do today like sending samples to a whole
biome or some of the you know other
companies second genome that can perform
these kinds of assays and having that
you know again get aggregated around you
in addition to all the other information
like we definitely see that you know
that kind of thing coming and in fact
what we're doing in the anson study has
at home sort of sampling of microbiome
and and then from the social networking
absolutely like we think you know again
these apps your diseased condition you
know patients like me have shown things
like that 23andme have shown the type of
connections that can be made based on um
you know the kind of information being
aggregated around you around your health
so we see the social interaction
component of that getting back to one of
the earlier questions as being maybe one
of the key incentive points for
motivating you to change behavior or to
understand how others like you were able
to change your behavior or go on to some
kind of intervention that
improve their condition and I'm happy if
I'm not totally getting out the question
happy to answer things via via email
okay if there are no more questions I
would like to once again thank dr. near
Chad for his presentation that was
really terrific do you have any final
comments
you
okay well thank you again and I like to
remind everyone that today's live
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through August 2 2016 you
receive an email from us alerting you
when it's available on demand and post
it on lab routes comm you're welcome to
for this announcement any colleagues who
weren't able to join in today thank you
for logging in today and participating
in today's live broadcast see you next
time bye bye